hi I'm Luna from Google and so yesterday
we will talk about knowledge fusion and
the knowledge base the trust the title
and the content it's a little different
from the title and the abstract in the
course announcement but the overlap is
big so this is collaboration with my
colleagues at Google including van of
gimme will call Camilo Kevin shalwar in
the way so I started working on the
quality of data especially quality of
integrated data since 2007 and the major
work is to figure out whether something
is correct and whether the source is of
good quality and whether some source
copies data from some other sources and
so on
so since then I was collecting various
examples from the web so to give my
talks and I have a whole lot of examples
about incorrect data imprecise data
about out-of-date data about ahead of
date data so this is kind of absurd
before it really happens and about how
rumors spread out from Wikipedia from
tweets from blogs and so on so I won't
go to it the details of any of this
example but today I'm going to give a
give you my only example so it started
in February this year I uploaded a paper
which I was submitting to vldb I
uploaded it to archive and the title is
knowledge based trust estimating the
trustworthiness of web sources and
that's kind of the major thing I will
talk about in this talk and then I'll
February 28th there is an article from
New Scientist about our article our
paper and most of the stuff in the
article is correct so for example the
first sentence says the trustworthiness
of a webpage might help it rise up
Google
ranking if the search giant stars to
marry equality by facts not just the
links however the headline of the news
is very misleading it is saying Google
wants to rank websites based on facts
not links and right after that there
have been a lot of news articles from at
least 200 newspapers or some of them
being possibly blogs and I'm sort of
plotting the distribution of the
articles over time you can see that the
peak is in the first week and then there
are news evencio like oh and I checked
last weekend and there are basically two
voices one voice is ah there is a lot of
misinformation on the web and I really
hope somebody able to tell me what is
true what is false and another kind of
voices no no I cannot trust that this
knowledge base the trust how can the
Machine tell me what is true and what is
the boss and what is the row of Google
on this and this will definitely slow
down the development of science so and
so forth in Seoul the best way to tell
you what's happening is to read some
quotes from a three Washington Post
articles and the first one is on March
2nd with title Google has developed a
technology to tell whether facts on the
Internet are true and it basically said
and concluded that it's unclear exactly
what Google plans to do with this new
technology if anything at all still even
the possibility of a search engine that
evaluates truth is a pretty incredible
breakthrough and it definitely gives new
meaning to the phrase let me google that
for you so this is very positive at this
point and then one week later so on
March 11th there was a second article by
another journalist titled uh the huge
implications of Google's idea to rek
sai's based on their accuracy and at
this point he was describing what has
happened
in the previous week and he said
Google's new research didn't explicitly
mention how this approach might rank
sighs contrarian websites the media have
been reporting this week that climate
change skeptics seem unnerved by the
direction that Google appears to be
heading if this ever moves closer to a
reality then they should be and after
that one day later the same journalist
right wrote another article saying why
some people are so terrified by the idea
of a Google truth machine and that he
started with there seems to be a fair
amount of confusion and some critical
points that I think people are missing
in a sense Google is both closer to and
farther from doing this than people seem
to realize later on he gave a lot of
like a good analysis good discussions
and finally he said it's a really
exciting and a brave new world where big
data and the smart engineers can indeed
in theory build tools and apps to help
protect us from his information
what remains up in the air right now is
precisely how and if these will be
implemented which is something I will
describe in this talk but back to my
example why do I say this is a data
quality example and so we see that I'm
using a wide arrow from this first
article to the rest of articles and the
thing arrow from the paper to the
articles and although there are some
articles very seriously like a quoting
our sentences in the paper showing our
experimental results but there are a lot
of articles basically repeating what the
first article says is best especially
repeating what the headline says and
there are a lot of information that
surprised me for example one news
article set up well they are going to
use New York Times and Wall Street
Journal as their gold standard and I
know obviously this is worrisome and I
couldn't remember where I mentioned that
all this - like newspapers okay
so now coming back to the
knowledge-based the trust and the
motivation is that we want to provide a
new perspective to evaluate Webster's
quality and currently we evaluate the
quality of the webpages web sources
using link based the signals such as
PageRank I'm sure everybody knows using
search log and the click-through rate
and also through some like web spam
detection all of these are exogenous
signals but what we want to do is we
want to evaluate the trustworthiness of
sources by the correctness of its
factual information in other words we
want to use some indigenious signals so
what do I mean by the correctness of the
factual information so if we have a web
page and we find out it claims ten facts
and out of it seven are correct and
three are wrong then we compute to the
accuracy as the number of current
effects out of the number of all fats
and in this example it is seven out of
ten is 0.7 right raw means whether it is
consistent with the real world so before
I even talk about how to do this let's
see why we care about this
so here the one of the motivation is
that the tale sources on the web
typically they are not well linked and
they may not be viewed a lot but they
can be useful let me use Google web
answers as an example so web answer is
basically they look at the top return
the answers for a question and then they
extract the answer from those snippets
and here if you ask who played the
stumble the stumbo is a ward winning
guitar music and then it will show you
somebody teacher shows how to play the
Dumble stops in Freddy Kings the stumble
so it gives you the answer this works
well however
if you ask about a not so popular song
like how who play guitar going home you
didn't get the answer it's not that this
piece of information is not on the web
it is just not in the top returned
results top returned the pages so for
example this website called backing
track guitar calm it gives very precise
information about the guitar players and
so on but it's PageRank is quite low
because it's one of the tail sources and
on the other hand without that a lot of
popular websites they may not really be
trustworthy and here I'm showing 15
gossip websites littered by this URL we
found that 14 out of these 15 have a
page ranked among the top 15 percent of
the websites so why because we all love
gossip and can the trustworthiness of
the sources help here so in our system
we compute this knowledge based the
trust abbreviated as KBT and the value
is between 0 and a 1 as I mentioned it's
the percentage of a correct facts out of
all facts and we can compute it for 5.6
millions of websites and about 120
millions of web pages here I'm showing
the distribution of Kb T for web sites
where we believe we have at least 100
facts and we see that the peak is 0.8
and 0.85 and more than half of the
services have a score over 0.8 however
there are also sources with low scores
this distribution sound kind of a make
sense because a lot of the web sites
gives decent content factual content so
how does that compare with the PageRank
and these plotting where the x axis is
KBT and
my axis is the PageRank show that they
are pretty much orthogonal and there are
a lot of some data sources between these
two lines they got correlated scores but
on the other hand there are a lot of
sources where the PBT is fairly high
that the PageRank is low especially in
this area so these are often the tale
sources with a high trustworthy contents
and I'm showing four examples here this
salary.com gives very good information
about the companies and the colleges
this website gives very good information
about the UK livestock this is what we
just saw the backing track guitar and
this gives very good information about
Korean drama it's not that a nobody I
mean it's not that many people care
about the Korean drama but still a lot
of people like my mom cares about it and
they can benefit from such websites if
she can read English and we sampled 100
websites where the KBT is about point
nine and we found we are very confident
that 85 of them are indeed trustworthy
for the rest of the 15 I will mention
them later on so on the other side we
also have sources where the PageRank is
high but KBT is fairly low and now let's
come back to the gossip websites we
found that all of them have a
knowledge-based trust in bottom 50%
meaning we believe it is the half of the
websites have a higher score than them
and we also find out that some foreign
websites have lower scores so for
example like this web page from Yahoo
Answers I mean I cannot tell if this is
correct however they mentioned Katherine
said Thais from New Zealand and from
Wikipedia and some other data sources we
know that ash is from Wales and the
third usage of this is that we can
recommend a website by
because by domains and this is because
we can compute the trustworthiness at
different granularities at the Webster
East granularity or at the webpage
granularity or at Webster's granularity
for every domain for every vertical so
for example if I search for food cheese
then it returns me something like
wikipedia.org cheese vici rancor this is
cheese plate is the cheese steak etc and
it tells me about the accuracy of the
information the kind of the coverage of
the information etc and that instead if
I search computer and will return me a
Wikipedia in different languages and
will return me an open-source software
directory this is free cold something
like Linux links so on and so forth ok
so at this point any question ok I hope
now you are already curious about how we
compute this knowledgebase the trust and
recall that I said we want to find out
the facts claimed by each web page and
the craftiness of each fact and both of
these tasks are very hard however we
have a project called knowledge wat
where we try to build a probabilistic
knowledge base we use the 16 extractors
extracting knowledge triples
subject-predicate object triples from
the whole web including 2.5 billions of
URLs and 28 millions of websites and we
extract from free text from Dom trees
from web tables and from annotations
according to for example schema.org
after that we put all of the extracts
together and try to decide what is
correct and what is not and we generate
a probability for each triple indicating
its probability of being true and then
we view the probabilistic knowledge base
so coming back to our plan now instead
of looking at the facts we want to look
at all of the extracted trip holes and
instead of looking at true or false we
want to look at the predicted
probabilities and then we compute an
average of the probabilities as the
accuracy of the web source so since life
is good for now but there is one
important thing that is missing here so
does anybody find out something missing
that's a good point
not the major thing certain of the fact
or that it's a true fact because those
are sort of distinct things you are
getting there so so these are all of the
extracted trip holes and the
probabilities are talking about the
probability for the trip hole to be true
to be consistent with the real world
yeah
however we are hoping we have some magic
way to find it out but before even
talking about that we actually find out
a lot of the triples are wrong because
of some extraction arrows and so there
might be trip holes wrongly extracted
not really claimed by the website and
this happens not only not only happens
but happens a lot so for example here we
extract the triple Obama nationality
Kenya from 2000 web pages and some of
the mark
we extracted for example this one says
Michelle Obama declares Obama is Kenyan
and America is mean and some of them
however are wrongly extracted like this
news headline says US will respect
winner of Kenyan election Obama says it
actually says the opposite Obama is not
Kenyan citizen and even for some
corrected presumably corrected triples
like Obama nationality USA we extracted
2500 times and a lot of them are
correctly extracted but still some of
them are wrongly extracted so if you
look at this screenshot it is a blog by
Team Stanley who is a historian of the
United States and the blog is talking
about Barack Obama's life story contains
myth now choose blah blah blah but it
doesn't say anything regarding his
nationality or place of birth etc and
that this United States is about Tim
Stanley rather than about a Barack Obama
so this is wrongly extracted so we
randomly sampled 25 false triples and we
found that 11 of them have some triple
identification errors for example they
take part of the album name as the album
artist and 11 of them have some entity
linkage arrows for example they take
Obamas father as Barack Obama and five
of them have some predicate linkage
arrows such as date of birth and place
of birth are wrongly matched and only
one of them have some source data error
in other words the extraction errors
actually dominate in Seoul we do not
want to blame a source for those wrongly
extractions so we want to identify the
extraction arrows so there are some
other challenges the second challenge is
that since we are going to compute the
average of the probability the
abilities better to be well calibrated
so what do I mean by well calibrated if
we're a trip hole I predict its
probability of being true is 0.7 there
we hope it's real probability of being
true is also 0.7 in other words if I
plot the predicted probability and that
real probability it should be a diagonal
line from 0 0 to 1 1 and what do I mean
by real probability from one fact
so actually what we do is we look at all
of the facts in the bucket with
probability 0.7 and we look at their
accuracy the accuracy can be considered
as the real probability and if the
bucket of triples where we predict a
probability of point 7 70% of them are
correct then the real probability for
those triples to be true is indeed 70
percent makes sense yes this an external
database or manual that's a good
question and the third challenge is
basically how to handle two large
sources or two small sources and on the
web the data sources are very different
and this is a distribution of the number
of triples extracted from each URL we
see that for 74% of the URLs there are
at most a 5 extracted triples and we
don't have enough triples for trust
within this evaluation we don't have the
statistical power and on the other hand
there are some large URLs where we have
more than 50k triples a lot of them
actually wrongly extracted and they
become the bottleneck in the
parallelization in computation so our
solution is to use a graphical model
such that we can predict it at the same
time what is the extraction correctness
was the triple correctness what is the
accuracy of the web source and what is
the precision recall of the extractor
and here we use unsupervised learning or
assembly supervise the learning when we
predict the correctness so when we try
to decide whether a fact or extracted
triple is correct we will lavaridge
agreement from different sources and the
we will give more trust to sources with
a higher trustworthy or higher accuracy
and on the other hand when we try to
decide if an extraction is correct we
will leverage the agreement between the
extractors and then we will give higher
trust to the extractors with higher
quality and another thing is since we
have a super pig and a super small
sources and extractors we break down the
large sources so they wouldn't be the
computation bottleneck and we merge the
small sources such that they could
borrow some statistical power from their
neighbors now let's see some a
high-level intuitions through some
examples
oops so let's see we have a three data
sources providing the affiliation
information for five database
researchers and let's say our sewers one
provides all of the correct affiliations
and a series - and a Series three makes
some mistakes here and there so if we do
voting where we trust the majority we
can actually do pretty well for the four
out of five researchers we get the
correct value the red and for my Cray we
have three sources giving three
different affiliations so there is a tie
in and we don't know which one is
correct now if we look at the red marks
it seems first one is more accurate more
trustworthy than source 2 and a source 3
so we want to give it a higher trust a
higher vote let's say
and then we can correctly decide that
UCI is the tract of variation for my
cray so we see that there is kind of a
chicken and egg problem higher
trustworthiness make us believe that
what it provides is more likely to be
true and more truthful facts make us
believe that this is more trustworthy so
now let's come to extractions and let's
see we have three extractors extracting
Harry Potter play actor actress from one
webpage and extractor one extracts four
of them extracted two extracts two of
them and the extractor three extracts
this three yes algorithms they could
learn different the patterns they could
apply different models and so on so we
do not assume any detail yeah okay so
now again let's do a boding and then it
seems these three are more likely to be
correct and this two are more likely to
be wrong and according to this is since
extractor one extracts all of the
correct things so has a higher recall
extractor to all of this extractions are
correct so it has a higher precision and
the extractor 3 has medium precision
recall and then now if we look at the
extractions again dan you and Rupert are
extracted by high precision extractors
so it is more likely to be true and on
the other hand eric is missed by a high
recoil extractor so it is more likely to
be wrong make sense okay so
this is what our graphical model looks
like we have four boxes the W box
represents a web source the a box
represents an extractor the D box extra
presents data item the attribute of some
particular entity or a subject predicate
pair and then the V box represents a
value for a data item so in other words
the object in a triple and these are our
variables X is our observation xew DV
means that extractor e extracts from
source W the data item D value V pair
and C WD v is that Webster's W indeed
provides the DV pair and this is a Latin
of variable and VD shows that what is
the correct value for this data item
this is again a Latin that variable a W
is the accuracy of the webservice it's a
parameter and the P er er the precision
recall of an extractor so note that this
is basically the knowledge base the
trust and what we do is recall that this
is chicken and egg problem and certainly
we want to do it in a yam fashion and we
first the computer the probability of a
web source provides a particular triple
conditioned on the extractor quality
this is more of predicting the
extraction correctness after that we
compute to the probability of a triple
conditional service quality and this is
more of prediction on the triple
correctness and then we compute the
source accuracy and we compute the
extract
precision and recall so these are by
bayazid analysis they can be considered
as the estep and this too can be
considered as n step however to simplify
it and make it scalable to the web data
we I mean we simplified it a lot and one
way to consider this is for web stories
we basically add some weight using the
extraction correctness and instead of
computing the act the average of the
triple correctness we compute the
average weighted by the extraction
correctness so far so good okay so
coming back to our examples we see that
for this triple we compute for this
particular correct extraction we compute
a probability of nearly 0.8 and for this
for this wrong extraction we compute a
probability of 0.1 3 regarding the
extraction correctness for the whole
triple we decide that the probability
for the triple to be correctly zero
because it does not have enough support
and if we go to this presumably correct
a triple then for the correct extraction
again we compute a very high extraction
correctness and for drawing extraction
we compute a low probability and for the
triple itself we compute a probability
of 1 and that this is mainly because of
the high contrast between the two triple
triples and if we look at the
distribution we see that for those of
the extractions where we compute a high
probability for the extraction to be
correct the number of web sources
providing us a is almost 1/2 more than
the number of webpages that claim Kenya
so recall that we want our computed
triple probability to be well calibrated
and this is our calibration curve and we
see that although this is kind of a
semi-supervised to learning but still
here it is clear aligned very well with
this diagonal line also on this two
sides it is very well aligned and
actually the majority of the triples
fall in this two areas here it is not
very well but on the other hand it does
not contain that many triples and this
is about triple practice and this shows
the extraction correctness so for some
of the triples we identify that it has
some type problem for example claiming
somebody's place of birth being let's
say a company which is obviously wrong
and for those things the they are
definitely wrongly extractions and
presumably ideally we should compute a
very low probability for the extraction
to be correct and that is this red line
so for 85% of the triples we compute a
probability of 0 for the extraction to
be correct on the other hand firsts for
the triples in freebase which presumably
are correct we found that for half of
them we compute a probability of over
0.7 for the extraction correctness note
that even corrected triples can be
wrongly extracted so some offers some
others we compute the low probabilities
and finally this is the PR curve and the
RLC curve of our predictions on the
triple correctness again they are in
kind of a good shape okay any questions
so far yes the trust
they as a distribution of your topic so
that you know like a website could be
more trustworthy uncertainty question
and actually instead of looking at the
whole website we do look at a website
predicate a pair unless if there are
only a few triples for a particular
predicate then we merge all such as more
predicates together so where'd you get
the model that has a constraints like
somebody has to be born in their country
so we we basically have some in the
schema in the knowledge base schema we
have some constraints about like if the
predicate is plays a birth then the
object should be location so the last
question I would like to discuss about
in this talk is whether we are really
ready to use knowledge based at rest and
from the question you possibly says that
the answer is not that positive and this
might be a little bit disappointed you
believed our you feel the results are
interesting and the techniques are
interesting however this actually shares
a lot of good research opportunities so
let's start talk about it in three
aspects input readiness the readiness of
technology and the readiness of our
output application so let's start with
input so we recall that we used 16
extractors to extract an odd knowledge
triples and even so the extraction is
very low-quality so on the one hand the
extraction is very sparse for 74% of the
knowledge of the URLs we have at most a
five triples and so we don't have enough
information to
this is trustworthy or not and in fact
we compute a reliable KBT only for less
than 20% of the websites and for far
less than 5% of the webpages and on the
other hand the extraction is not only
sparse but of very low quality I really
hate to say what is the accuracy of the
extraction but it already shows up here
it is as low as 11.5% meaning if I
extract the 10 triples their Knight of
them are wrong
so I mean so so the expectation is
likely to be like a garbage in the
garbage out although we work very very
hard but still we might miss some
wrongly extracted triples still predict
them as correct as a result for those
web sources we will compute a relatively
lower accuracy trustworthiness for them
and another problem is that we have an
imbalance between the extraction
extraction on free texts and extraction
on palm trees down trees have some
structure can be considered as semi
structured data and they are we have a
better extraction quality and for free
texts we have lower quality and among
the 100 simple services with KBT over
point nine ninety-five percent of them
are mainly semi structured data but
whether it said correctly or the weapons
my and you extract more there's a good
question here actually when I say the
accuracy is 11.5%
it means among all of the extractions
among all of the extracted triples
11.5 percent of the triples are
considered to are really true
consistent with the real world and
therefore the wrong tree posts yet some
of them are indeed provided by some bad
sources however recall that I said that
we did our sampling on 25 round-trip
and the 24 of them are because of
extraction arrows how do you how we
evaluate the accuracy we take the we
take the freebase as our gold standard
however freebase only tells us what is
true it doesn't tell us what is wrong
and we apply a local closed world
assumption
meaning if freebase have some
information about Barack Obama's
children and then for whatever not in
freebase we will consider them as wrong
in our gold standard because we assume
once it has some information about stata
item about entity attribute it has
complete information so that's local
close the word however if freebase
doesn't say anything about Obama's
children then whatever we see we say and
no we don't know if it is correct or not
yes the difference you're describing to
truth versus accuracy so truth is
basically saying whether given a triple
subject predicate object whether it is
correct or not correct
makes absolute sense in the physical
world and fantasy is triples reflect
being what you wanted to lose that want
them to reflect so you're saying that
that's a precision thing that's an
accuracy thing truth means that it's
true
physically better triples with
creationism
no that's might be that your algorithm
just fine no that's true it has to be
truth to be consistent I guess there are
two parts of it and one part of it is
whether this is already kind of decided
to be true or false and whether we have
in the physical world we already know it
is true or false not that everything is
as simple as saying somebody's
nationality being something and in that
case like the global warming thing I
mean it is fuzzy and we basically sort
of leverage the agreement between the
sources and the lavaridge and we trust
that the authoritative sources more than
other sources so we make our decisions
on both of them on the other hand we
also have this kind of a simple fact and
sophisticated facts and for example
coming back to the to the to the news
headline when I say when it says Google
is going to use facts not links to rank
the websites it is false but if it
doesn't say in not facts then I mean
whether it is true or false it is not
clear so for those sophisticated facts
we even do not have a way to sort of
represent it you
the knowledge triples and finally
basically here I'm saying factual
information I'm not saying anything
about predictions or anything about the
opinions and so on
that's that answer your question in
terms of if our goal is to extract
corrected triples then it would be good
to narrow down the domains however if
our goal is to evaluate the quality of a
web source we should look at the facts
it's really now this thing will get you
everyone face by forcing a different
basically the truth panic a variable
kind of time and I think markets and so
on so all those he seems that if you
never get a Comcast automate then you
could have more precise meaning on
whether it's accurate or not I was
posting would be true but you know so
there were basically two parts let me
first to say about the second part
an example is it is raining now it is
not true in general for the whole world
but if we say it is raining
now in pallidal at the Stanford area
then it is possibly true or false and in
that case we actually make sure that you
know knowledge triple it is very
specific so for example when we say this
is the height of somebody we wouldn't
say just a 163 we will say 163
centimeter or some five five food etc
and for your first statement like some
of the statements is based on some
assumptions with this assumptions this
is correct but with some other
assumptions this is incorrect this is
very interesting research topic and we
currently work on finding out at
different perspectives because the
perspectives basically are based on some
assumptions for example if you consider
the liberal view and conservative view
in politics it also has some assumptions
associated with it it's hard to say if
it is true or false but associated with
some assumption there we can roughly say
yeah it possibly is true or false with
this assumption yes fully correct you
would register those as two confirming
sources this is a question
basically what if the data is one day
discrete data from another source or
copy data from another source or
whatever and I like this question so
much that I spent five years doing
research on it detecting the copying
relationships between the structured
data and our basic ideas things I think
we have time so our basic idea is like
this if you have some multi choice
answers questions for for the students
and now you get to answer sheets and
they are exactly the same and both of
them have full score will you say what
must the copy
without any prior knowledge about
whether they're good students or bad
that's so good students you possibly
wouldn't say we're hat has to cop it
from the other because they can both be
excellent students and give perfect
answers however if you see to answer
sheets exactly the same and they make a
lot of common mistakes at this point you
would say okay why do you make so many
common mistakes so that's the intuition
and that we use the intuition to find
out copying relationship and that we
will lower the boat for the copiers yeah
so however for this actually comes to
this page this slide so for this copy
detection although we did so much work
and we found that it works perfectly for
not perfectly works very well for like
thousands of data sources we just cannot
get it scale to billions of data sources
it's just too many data sources when we
need to have a complexity of oh and
square so that part is still left out
for this work but it is important so I
see you so we haven't said much about
how you're extracting facts from from
natural language is hard enough and then
presumably that's why most of your
accurate facts come from the
semi-structured run but but you know i
guess you know how could that be
improved with better with better text
parser so so let me try to be really i
think of funding here are there any code
here doing natural language processing a
lot right and do you think we are fully
ready for extracting knowledge from the
web arbitrary webpages
I work on deep dive wishes yeah so that
somewhere in between thinking and LP is
very necessary or used a supporting tool
so somewhere in the middle
the interesting thing is to my
understanding it is about the Geoscience
domain not the full web right but yeah I
mean like a previous level those things
are are I think where we have decent
extraction capabilities as I said from
our extractions were the even from the
same project we found that the
extraction some free tax is the quality
is much lower than than the extraction
on semi structured data and we do have
our some LP tools to do the annotation
for web contents and then we apply like
this in supervision etcetera to learn
the patterns but it is still error-prone
and one of the reasons of these errors
is because we don't have enough negative
examples but I notice that if I plug in
three keywords and four keywords on my
computer I get certain results ah if I
plug in the same exact keywords into
somebody else's continued I'll get
different results
ah is that because of previous history
on the computer so it is more of the
personal search so I assume you are
talking about Google I don't know if
other of like a Bing is doing similar
things but Google has this personal
search and if you look at your search
history look at your click-through
history and then it will decide okay
when you talk about Apple you mean the
the iPhone company you are not talking
about what to eat yeah and maybe
for like for people who plan to apples
it is different
probably face what I search history
stored on their enemies yes if you have
multiple user logins
a PC is this past history kept in the
per user database or is it more global
it is per user in a very likely per
machine well so let me put it in this
way if you if so if you long if you use
the same let's say a gmail account then
it is per user if you do not log in it
is more per machine yeah basically
attributed to different instead of a
personal search so we talked about the
input readiness and it's not that ready
yet and for the techniques we already
mentioned the some of them like the
simple versus sophisticated facts about
different perspectives that a copy
detection and the one thing I didn't
mention that much in my graphical model
is that we assume for each subject
predicate pair there is a single trace
which is obvious obviously not true so
like a person could author multiple
books and a movie started to play in
multiple movies and why do we use this
single trees model we do have a multi
trees model but if we compare the
results the single trees model is so
much better and when we use multi choose
model the preceded job
significantly and this is also
associated with the fact that we have a
very bad extraction so if we use the
single cheese model yes we made some of
the correct effects but on the other
hand and we filtered the huge amount of
noise and another thing we don't capture
is the value similarity so for example
we have some extremely ghost standard or
what we decided to be correct a saying
that somebody was born in Auckland
but on the other hand we see a sewer
saying somebody was born in San
Francisco and then we say this is
incorrect
however what this San Francisco might be
just a referring to the big large San
Francisco area and another thing is I
think one of the questions mention about
this is kind of a triple filtering we
found we cannot evaluate based on all of
the extracted triples recall that I said
that we sampled 100 websites for 15 of
them we are not confident that they are
trustworthy and actually two of them we
extracted triples irrelevant to the
topic of the sewers for example for one
of the web stores it gives the business
listings in Brazil but all of our
extracted triples says this city belongs
to the state this city has this zip code
this state belongs to Brazil and so on
so it doesn't have anything regarding
the business listing and then just to
say this is a trustworthy sources
because of the geography information
correctness this is not fair and we have
12 sources where we basically evaluate
on the trivial triples and the trivial
basically means something that is
obviously true and as an example we have
a source that provides hotel listings
and most of our extracted triples says
what is the accommodation type of this
hotel and 95% of the
tights our hotel and if you see this is
a hotel website where all we know is
those hotels have a commendation type
hotel you really can say this is a
trustworthy source so we need to do all
of the things to filter the triples that
are you look irrelevant give lower
weight to the trivial triples etc and
finally let's look at the output
application readiness the customer
readiness there are basically two usages
of the trustor within its core the first
one is to predict the quality for
websites and webpages and to use this we
have to combine this with some other
signals like like the page rank and the
click-through rate in a current layer is
not super clear how to do the
combination and a second application is
to recommend sources if I want to
collect knowledge about this vertical
regarding food cheese variety what are
the data stories is where I can get a
lot of good high accurate information
and here the interesting thing is we can
consider those verticals or domains as
head verticals and the tail verticals
for head verticals like a movie like
song we know what had a good data
sources and for movie let's say I mean
you know you want to go to M DB and you
don't need any recommendation for it but
for for the long tails we have some
recommendations but because the best
positi of the extractions we might miss
some good sources and here it actually
comes to my sort of a suggestion to the
research community and I think now if
you look at the like a knowledge
curation knowledge extraction knowledge
meant management systems there are they
have done very good job but it's more
about the head entities and the head
verticals
and however if I have a company and I
want to extract knowledge for a
particular hat vertical what am I what
will I do I will buy data from some
authoritative sources which everybody
knows and there I will hire 50 engineers
to scrape the data for it
and then I have high quality data and I
can refresh the data from time to time
and I don't need to worry about the
quality issue but for the kind of
arbitrary extractions as I mentioned the
quality can be quite low on the other
hand this engineering approach it does
not scale to the tail entities to the
tail verticals where we might have like
millions of tail verticals but we don't
know what other good source is and we
don't know where to get the good data
and so I'm hoping the research could
really help for those body to tail data
for those long tails and so here the
cotton arm thing is we want to leave no
valuable data behind including tail
verticals tail sources tail entities
tail attributes and also data from let's
say a long time ago kind of maybe out of
data but it would be valuable history
data so typically I would end my talk
with some ago links and here I will end
my talk with some not go links and for
knowledge-based trust
org and knowledge based trust the
dot-com these are registered during the
news buzz week and we have no control of
it and then we wouldn't be responsible
for lack of information there and with
this I will end my talk so yes I think
this can be considered as a new field to
decide the trustworthiness to decide the
truthfulness
however I mean if you get boosted with
more trustworthy data then I mean you
will have more traffic just decided well
first of all the data doesn't make you
anymore why I answered by thousand great
facts just to slip the one untrue that I
want you to help so that is a very good
point and this is actually one of the
challenges I mentioned we need to figure
out so first we need to figure out what
is the true bonus of those information
if a lot of the information is basically
saying the sky is blue birds could fly
etcetera and that could shouldn't be
given a lot of weight in a second
I mean smarter people they can put a lot
of non-trivial correcting information
and then say hey this this singer sings
to this song and this politician is from
this country bla bla bla bla and then
finally he says oh by the way Obama is
really from Kenya and then we would be
biased by the many like a crack the
facts so that's something very
interesting and that we are still
considering how to solve that problem
conflict between authorities the case in
mind the discovery of proteins which was
denigrating for a number of years until
was a Nobel Prize for that sort of
knowledge coming out being denied so
this actually is related to one of the
research ideas which we call time
machine and for time machine there are
basically two things we want to discover
one is the evolving truth and something
is correct at some point for example
using the simplest example I'm working
for Google now and five years ago I'm
working for another company and ten
years ago I'm a graduate student from
u-dub something like this so the cheese
is evolving over time and the second
thing is the sort of the belief of truth
so for example at some point people
believe the the the Sun is rotating
around the earth and it is certainly not
true but at some point it is believed to
be true and I believe there should be a
lot of like research can be done on this
yes melodye authoritative sources this
is actually a very interesting question
what is the best way to validate the
authoritative sources and we found that
because the majority of the data sources
they do not intention intentionally give
bad information and typically if
something is correct then there will be
more sources claiming it or more
authoritative sources claiming it if an
authoritative source is claiming
something opposite to most of the other
sources then it is really a question
mark of whether it is true or false we
might compute the probability not really
zero but like point four point five but
it's a question mark it basically says
we are not sure if this correct or not
different leading-edge Sciences usually
of course everybody else is wrong so you
can't do it by quantity and let's say we
are all about scientific things and at
some point I come up with a new
discovery which unfortunately is wrong
but because I'm a bad source and for
that discovery it will be given a low
probability and because you're a good
source and if you come up with some
discovery you will get much higher
probability although you conflict with
the rest of the world and you will have
a higher probability to start with and
hopefully with more and more people like
agreeing with you the probability will
go up assuming all of the sources have
the same quality and then recall that we
iteratively compute these probabilities
and equality until it converges or until
a certain number of runs so this is a
purely unsupervised way and a second way
is that we bootstrap the quality of a
data source using some gold standard for
example using the freebase with the
local closed world assumption just not
sure this 98% yeah I the the only thing
I could say is I mean there are
definitely problems and there are
definitely wrong decisions but according
to the results of this is what we get
enemy work and ligament to characterize
what are the sources of the inaccurate
information like you know the Obama was
born in Kenya clearly that's from you
know politically motivated science you
know if you mentioned gossip sites all
other other broad broad categories or
sources will be inaccurate information
you can discover we haven't done it
would be very interesting visit to your
ranking function what do you say
harmonic likelihood and that's basically
the m-step that's a true and step but
then it turns out to be very complex and
there are some paper I couldn't remember
so I remember the complexities and to
the power of three and then it wouldn't
the scale for the web scalability and so
that's why we what are your expectations
to where this is all headed to what
extent will this be common painting near
deterministic in what kind of timeframe
my present does it's very interesting
with more is a philosophical discussion
of what constitutes truth and
how do you define a fact and that you
identify the way of determining if
something is accurate or not as opposed
to a science or an engineering
discipline where you write the code and
you come up and answer at the back end
where do you think this is heading and
how quickly will you be getting to
something that's solid first let's talk
about regarding solid or regarding I
mean one this iteration would stop so
what we found is that because of the
simplification in the end step so we
found that if we consider only the
service accuracy then it does not
necessarily converge and however if the
number of trip holes is far more than
the number of sources then our
observation is that it typically
converges but for this particular like
experiment we didn't really go until it
converges because that's just too
expensive and we stopped after five
rounds and we found that after five
rounds the results are pretty much
stable and actually after starting from
the third around the results are pretty
much stable and then for your question
about a where at least two do you
basically mean what I just said or do
mean where the research results will
lead to your learning did you go at some
point this might actually roll out and
become part of a standard product and
the main part of the Google replacement
per page ranking or a strong supplement
what
my friend before you think it gets to
that level of liability there are indeed
I mean many like collaborations where we
are trying to use this to decide whether
extractions are correct we are trying to
recommend web sources for verticals we
are even trying to find out what is the
quality of a website etc yes 27 symptoms
and get a better diagnosis than a doctor
so Google now launched a something like
a medical knowledge panel and basically
it will say for some disease what are
the symptoms and you can you can
basically search disease by symptom or
symptom by disease
I don't know how mature it is and what
is the coverage by for this what I heard
is this is definitely not something that
they get from sources they hire doctors
to come up with this quick comment the
maximum likely typically converges in
distribution doesn't work doesn't
converge on the number if you go to the
loop you don't can watch our numbers to
get distributions so your point is you
may have to report the distribution I
think that would be more interesting
this say these sources say that yes we
say no report the distribution like you
do some of the other real-time news
whatever how many papers bla bla science
can tell you often things can watch a
distribution but not single numbers all
it takes down the way around
yeah you can see Rosa because especially
because we sort of make this simple
single truth assumption for every data
item subject predicate pair and for the
objects I mean the for each object we
compute some probability and that's kind
of a distribution for the probabilities
of the candidate objects certainly it is
not true that a distribution for each
object for each triple
you